[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club de
constitutionnalist
bonjourina merci beaucoup d'être dans ce
club on est ravi de vous recevoir
Jean-Philip de rosier de retour bonjour
jeip de rosier merci également d'être là
on va parler avec vous du discours
d'Emmanuel Macron sur la institution il
veulent notamment élargir le champ du
référendum une réforme constitutionnelle
peut-elle aboutir vous allez nous le
dire et Audrey on parlera avec vous de
décentralisation oui et puis de la forme
d'autonomie de lacse qu'Emmanuel Macron
a réévoqué hier ça a donné des idées à
la Bretagne à l'Alsace la nouvelle
Aquitaine et l'Occitanie on verra tout
ça d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans
nos
[Musique]
régions et l'info dans nos région c'est
le Congrès des sapeurs pompiers de
France qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui à
Toulouse pour en parler on retrouve
Olivier Richefou bonjour merci d'être
avec nous président du département de la
Mayenne vous êtes également président de
la Conférence nationale des services
d'incendie et de secours Olivier Richou
quels sont les enjeux de ce
congrès ce sont des enjeux extrêmement
importants après la période sans doute
plus calme cet été que celle de l'année
précédente mais on voit bien que ces
phénomènes climatiques vont avoir une
influence importante sur nos concitoyens
et donc sur les services de secours
indescendi et n'oublions pas non plus
que nouson a nous avons un deuxième
phénomène qui nous impacte c'est cette
désertification médicale qui amène sans
doute une sollicitation supérieure et
quotidienne auprès de nos sapurs
pompiers justement il y a Géral haranin
qui sera présent évidemment c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur mais Aurélien
Rousseau le ministre de la santé sera
présent et et ça c'est beaucoup plus
rare c'est un bon
signal c'est très rare je je je pense
même alors c'est le 129e congrès je n'ai
pas épouché les archives des congrès
précédents depuis autant d'années mais
c'est sans doute une des premières fois
qu'un ministre de la Santé et qu'un
ministre de l'Intérieur seront ensemble
à la même table un congrès des pompiers
et j'y vois un signal de très grande
qualité parce que nous connaissons tous
cette cette gu guerre entre les blancs
et les rouges il faut qu'elle cesse il
faut que ces plateformes communes de
traitement d'appel promises par le
Président de la République ce numéro
unique se met en place les réticences
viennent de la santé il faut donc
travailler ensemble dans intérêt de nos
concitoyens il y a eu on s'en souvient
des mégafeu à l'été 2022 l'été 2023 a
été plus calme en tout cas moins
catastrophique sur le front des
incendies est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on
a tiré les leçons de ces
mégafeu en partie oui à chaque fois
qu'il y a des grands événements les
saort montpiier sont habitués à faire un
fameux
rétex mais les enseignements ils vont
surtout se traduire par des moyens
matériels supplémentaires le
gouvernement a décidé d'accompagner les
territo d'accompagner les départements
d'accompagner les en mettant en vre ce
qui s'est appelé les pactes capacitaires
ça n'a pas produit encore d'effet
puisque il faut le temps de construire
les matériels qui vont ainsi être
financés mais oui les les enseignements
ont été tirés et je crois que nous
serons encore mieux préparés la
prochaine fois il y a eu un dernier mot
Olivier rich il y a une loi qui a été
voté au Parlement sur pour améliorer la
prévention de la lutte dans la lutte
contre les incendies est-ce que c'est
suffisant ou est-ce qu'il y a des
chantiers qui sont encore en cours il y
a encore des chantiers en cours parce
que vous savez dans dans notre belle
organisation française nous votons des
lois les députés les sénateurs votent
des lois et je les en remercie mais il y
a des décrets et et on voit bien que
tous les décrets ne sont pas encore
sortis et donc nous attendons avec
impatience notamment un décret qui doit
être signé par le ministre de la Santé
peut-être le le fera-t-il demain ou
samedi matin à l'occasion de sa présence
qui est celui qui doit définir le la
zone de défense dans laquelle nous
devons expérimenter ces plateformes
communes qui entre parenthèse existe
déjà dans plus d'une vingtaine de
départements mais il faut encore
expérimenter alors expérimentons mais
obtenons rapidement la signature de ce
décret par exemple merci beaucoup merci
Olivier richfou d'avoir été avec nous
alors que souv ce congrès des sapeurs
pompiers de France merci d'avoir été
notre invité on va passer au débat de ce
club on va parler du discours d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la constitution avant d'en
parler avec vous Anne Charlette Mina et
Jean-Philippe de rosier on va voir ce
qu'a dit le chef de l'État il souhaite
notamment réformer la Constitution en
ouvrant le champ du rférendum Flora
sauvage élargir le champ du référendum
c'est l'une des annonces faites par
Emmanuel Macron lors d'un discours
devant le Conseil constitutionnel
mercredi il existe encore des domaines
importants pour la vie de la nation qui
échappent au champ de l'article 11 de
notre Constitution le chef de l'État
souhaite aussi simplifier la procédure
du Rip le référendum d'initiative
partagé qui n'a pas pu être appliqué ni
contre la privatisation d'Aéroport de
Paris ni contre la réforme des retraites
car il est soumis à des conditions très
strictes sa mise en œuvre doit être plus
simple et les seuils permettant son
usage comme peut-être ces procédures
devraient dès lors être revu autre
annonce Emmanuel Macron s'est prononcé
en faveur de l'inscription de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la Constitution faisant référence
au désaccord au Parlement sur le sujet
j'ai exprimé mon souhait le 8 mars
dernier que nous puissions trouver un
texte accordant les points de vue entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat et
permettant de convoquer un congrès à
Versailles je souhaite que ce travail de
rapprochement des points de vue reprenne
pour aboutir dès que possible pour faire
aboutir ces réformes il faudrait que le
projet de loi constitutionnel soit
adopté dans les mêmes termes par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat avant
d'être soumis au vote des 35è des
parlementaires réunis en congrès ù via
un référendum devant les Français la
manœuvre n'est pas gagnée en l'absence
d'une majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale et d'un Sénat à majorité LR
Anne Charlen bin on va commencer en
parlant de cette élargissement du champ
du référendum est-ce que ça va permettre
de répondre au malaise démocratique
selon vous c'est la grande question euh
au fond le référendum c'est une
consultation du peuple pour dire oui ou
non à une loi qui a déjà été
discutée la la question qui se pose
c'est pas tant à mon avis le le champ
des sujets mais l'utilisation véritable
et effective de cet outil qui
rappelons-le est un pouvoir propre du
président donc c'est au président de
décider quand il voudra soumettre un
référendum au français donc souhaitons
que l'élargissement de ces listes
l'amène à élargir tout simplement son
usage du référendum parce que faut pas
croire que les deux vont de pair est-ce
que ça aussi c'est une voix du
changement démocratique en tout cas ce
qu'on voit c'est que la confiance est
rompu et que ça ce sont des des liens
qui mettent souvent beaucoup de temps à
se retisser oua et il va falloir plus
qu'un élargissement du référendum pour
retisser cette confiance j'en le champ
du référendum est déjà large la
politique économique sociale et
environnementale on a déjà eu un
référendum sur la politique économique
sociale ou environnemental non je ne
crois pas donc on peut l'élargir autant
qu'on veut mais autant encore faut-il
l'utiliser et précisément la confiance
est rompue et et la confiance n'est pas
seulement rompue des citoyens envers les
pouvoirs publics et les institutions
mais les pouvoirs publics leurs
représentants n'ont plus confiance en
les citoyens pour activer le référendum
les seuls référenda qu'on a activé les
principaux depuis le général de Gaulle
c'est pour ratifier des traités
internationaux on na pas toujours été
bien avisé parce que pour s'exprimer sur
un traité international il faut le lire
il faut le comprendre il est souvent
technique et on a vu ce que ça pouvait
donner sur le traité constitutionnel
européen avec le 29 mai 2005 le le le
résultat n'était
pas était clair évidemment le le rejet
n'était pas celui espéré et attendu et
avec des conséquences qui ont conduit à
remettre en cause cette parole du peuple
2 ans plus tard avec la
ratifation bah sans doute en tout cas ça
y contribue largement ensuite le
référendum est souvent considéré comme
l'idéal démocratique non ce n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga de la démocratie
Charl bzina vient de dire que c'est
soumettre un projet de loi qui a déjà
été discuté je ne vois pas à quel moment
est-ce qu'il est discuté précisément
c'est un texte qui est directement
soumis au peuple qui ne peut pas être
discuté or on n'a jamais rien trouvé de
mieux pour faire les lois que des
parlementaire le le le débat législatif
pour fabriquer la loi pour l'améliorer
pour trouver les meilleures solutions
c'est une vertu démocratique et euh par
le référendum on se prive de cela il y a
d'autres mécanismes qui permettent de
faire participer les citoyens plutôt que
le seul référendum Emmanuel Macron hier
il a mis en garde cont contre une
concurrence des légitimité entre le
référendum et le vote du Parlement elle
peut exister pour vous cette concurrence
des légitimité
euh la question c'est finalement de les
articuler parce que des légitimités dans
la démocratie il y en a forcément deux
et il y en a forcément une seule à la
source de tout c'est le peuple c'est
justement le le pouvoir du peuple donc
au fond la concurrence des légitimités
moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit le le
référendom qu'actionne ou qu' ou qui
pose des problèmes avec ça ce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier c'est que l'idée du
référendum et ce que je voulais dire
notamment avec cette cette issue de la
discussion c'est que en fait le le
référendum c'est une ratification c'est
pas nécessairement une participation
plus importante alors on a connu ces
derniers temps différents mécanismes de
consultation avec les conventions
citoyennes et cetera mais là encore
l'autre problème c'est qu'on le
déconnecte de la décision donc au fond
je crois que ce qui est nécessaire c'est
de montrer tout simplement qu'un autre
usage du pouvoir est possible et que le
peuple peut être consulté entendu et
aussi intéressé aux affaires publiques
je suis pas nécess ement garanti que
l'élargissement de ce champ
l'élargissement des conditions du Rip
soit les réponses que les Français
attendent au problèmes en cours et on
pourrait même avoir l'impression moi
c'est c'est le sentiment que j'ai eu à
l'issue du discours d'hier que ces
réformes constitutionnelles qui étaient
d'ailleurs toutes annoncées depuis assez
longtemps sont un peu les réformes de la
majorité relative c'est-à-dire que
Emmanuel Macron doit chercher des
accords avec la droite doit chercher des
accords avec le Sénat doit chercher des
accords avec les territoires et Infiné
avec les Français mais ça n'a pas été
forcément son objectif premier et donc
on on voit bien que c'est des
concessions qui ont été faites hier mais
pas forcément une réforme d'ampleur
comme on aurait pu l'ou on va revenir
sur est-ce que cette promesse cette
réforme d'ampleur peut être tenable pour
finir sur le référendum il a également
dit qu'il voulait simplifier le
référendum d'initiative partagé en
abaissant le seuil de citoyens
nécessaire pour déclencher ce rip c'est
une bonne chose Jean-Philippe deosier ce
n'est pas une mauvaise chose parce que
aujourd'hui les conditions c'est un/ ce
des parlementaires ça c'est ça peut être
atteint relativement facilement en tout
cas aisément 185 et 1/0e du corps
électoral ça c'est tout bonnement
impible disons-le clairement ça veut
dire aujourd'hui à peu près 5 millions
d'électeurs les pétitions les plus
populaires sur Internet où on agit par
un simple clic atteignent tout juste 3
millions et encore ça se produit
peut-être une fois le seul référendum
d'initiative partagée qui avait vu le
jour c'était sur Aéroport de Paris
2019-2020 il a franchi 1 million pour
arriver à 11 bon c'était déjà un très
beau score donc là justement il veut la
baisser à 1 million il veut alors j'ai
pas entendu de chiffre mais si vous avez
l'information c'est c'est très bien
effectivement 1 million c'est c'est un
chiffre qui me paraît tout à fait
raisonnable après il faut aussi voir le
délai dans lequel est-ce que les
signatures sont recueillies parce que si
100 million en 15 jours c'est pas 1
million en 2 ans hein et et là
actuellement c'est 9 mois si on reste
dans ce délai là effectivement 1 million
c'est c'est tout à fait euh atteignable
en revanche il y a deuxème élément dans
ce RIP qui est que si on atteint les
seuils il y a pas forcément de
référendum parce que il y a la procédure
parlementaire qui doit reprendre son
cours et si les deux assemblées
examinent le texte alors il y a pas de
référend nont pas même pas l'obligation
de l'adopter elles doivent l'examiner
quit à le rejeter et dans ce cas-là il
n'y a pas de référendum c'est seulement
si elle ne l'examine pas dans les 6 mois
qu'il y a référendum et je pense que
donc c'est pas seulement un abaissement
du seuil qu'il faut revoir je pense que
ce vou là il faudrait le il faudrait le
supprimer et je voudrais ajouter un mot
sur la concurrence des légitimités bien
sûr qu'elle peut exister mais elle
existe d'autant plus quand on l'attise
et précisément lorsque un élu direct du
peuple a peu de considération peu de
respect pour d'autres institutions qui
sont aussi les élus du peuple ou en tout
cas représentatifs de la nation vous
aurez compris que je parle du Parlement
là il y a des concurrence de légitimité
et on peut parfaitement travailler en
harmonie pour justement ne pas attiser
ces concurrences pour rechercher la
complémentarité et associer le peuple
leurs institutions et les décideurs
c'est ça le grand chantier le grand
chantier à mon avis c'est en effet de de
retrouver une voix sereine de dialogue
entre les pouvoirs publics et le peuple
précisément cet abaissement des
conditions du Rip il faut le dire le le
le rip résu d'une réforme
constitutionnelle qui a ouvert un
chantier presque euh intenable dès le
départ donc il a été fait pour ne pas
être utilisé il a plus ou moins été fait
pour ne pas être utilisé alors est-ce
que c'est une réforme constitutionnelle
en 2 temps est-ce qu'on s'est dit qu'on
allait y revenir il est temps d'y
revenir et peut-être aussi de voilà de
de moderniser un petit peu cet outil
pour que le le le peuple ait envie d'y
aller avec la concurrence des
légitimités cette idée de dire qu'on ne
pourra pas revenir sur une loi discuter
ça aussi ça verrouille quand même
beaucoup donc voilà il y a encore des
pas à franchir est-ce que c'est risqué
aujourd'hui politiquement de faire un
référendum en France est-ce que on en
parla un petit peu le peuple ne répond
pas plus à celui qui pose la question
qu'à la question posée alors tout dépend
de ce que l'on recherche avec un
référendum le général de Gaulle était
assez Friant de rechercher justement
cette adhésion populaire à travers la
question c'était moins la question qui
l'intéressait que la réponse qu'on
allait lui donner personnellement donc
si c'est ce type d'adhésion de de une
forme de responsabilité politique qui
est recherché on peut tout à fait
considérer que le référendum est un bon
outil évidemment le peuple va être tenté
de répondre avec ses aspirations du
moment avec ses grognes aussi du moment
mais ça peut être aussi un des avantage
de cet outil même si ça peut être en
effet son risque et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que le référendum est craint
par les gouvernants donc élargir le
champ il faut aussi en élargir l'usage
surtout il un risque politique depuis
1969 tout référendum s'est traduit soit
par un des inérêts total soit par un
séisme et et et donc oui celui qui pose
la question et et engage sa
responsabilité notamment avec le
précédent de 69 même s'il n'en tient pas
compte Jacques Chirac en 2005 avec le
nom au Traité constitutionnel européen N
a enfin on a tiré les conséquences du
nom c'estàd qu'il n'a pas ratifié
évidemment mais il n'a pas démissionné
il avait dit qu'il ne le ferait pas et
il n'était pas tenu de le faire parce
que précisément le référendum porte sur
le texte et pas sur la personne il y a
une façon de éviter cela c'est
de poser plusieurs questions le même
jour de faire un référendum multiple
avec plusieurs textes qui sont soumis au
peuple alors ça ne peut pas être des
préférences hein c'est pas est que vous
voulez qu'on aille plutôt dans telle
direction plutôt dans telle direction
c'est voici trois textes et vous est-ce
que vous validez les trois de sur 3 un
sur TR ce qui permet de dépersonnaliser
un petit peu parce que précisément ce
n'est que si on adhère à tout on rejette
tout que là il y a la personnalisation
alors il a pas parlé du référendum hier
Emmanuel Macron audre il a aussi abordé
des thèmes qui plent bien au cén oui en
parlant de décentralisation j'ouvrirai
le chantier d'une nouvelle étape de
décentralisation ce sont ces mots il a
précisé qu'il se concerterait avec les
parties prenantes et les présidents des
deux chambres du Parlement le chef de
l'État qui n'a pas détaillé plus que ça
mais qui confirme que son objectif c'est
de permettre plus de clarté et
d'efficacité dans les responsabilités
alors le Sénat a un peu été échaudé hein
sur ce sujet depuis le premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron on se souvient de la
loi tr DS qui traitait de la
décentralisation les ambitions de la
chambre haute avaient été très limitées
on s'en souvient pour s'en prémunir les
sénateurs ont fait 15 propositions
transpartisanes portées par Gérard
Larcher plus d'autonomie fiscale pour
les communes des maires qui gardent la
main sur le logement un meilleur statut
de l'élu dans ces propositions il y
avait aussi l'inscription de la
différenciation dans la constitution et
la rénovation du cadre constitutionnel
des outres-mères sur ces points il
semble que le Sénat a été entendu par le
chef de de l'État voici ce qu'il a dit
hier indivisible en effet ne signifie
pas
uniforme l'idéal républicain est assez
fort pour accueillir les adaptations les
spécificités les particularités l'unité
de la France après tant de siècles de
centralisation dont chacun aujourd'hui
perçoit la limite et les impasses
supportera cette répartition nouvelle
des pouvoirs mieux je le crois
profondément notre unité sera plus forte
et à ce titre tout particulièrement
l'ensemble de nos autres maire doivent
pouvoir être mieux reconnus dans notre
Constitution et si le consensus se
dégage en ce sens donnez lieu aussi à
des évolution du texte
constitutionnel c'est pas tout Orian le
chef de l'État a aussi déclaré c'était
très attendu depuis sa visite à numea en
juillet dernier que l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie nécessitera à coup sû
une révision constitutionnelle avec un
nouveau statut une promesse pour le
début d'année prochaine il a aussi
évoqué la Corse en confirmant
l'ouverture d'une voie vers une forme
d'autonomie dans la République avec une
nuance tout de même cela ne se fera que
si un consensus se dégage parmi les
forces politiques du pays et on sait que
le groupe LR au Sénat y est
particulièrement réticent d'ailleurs le
chef des LR au Sénat Bruno rotaillot a
fait savoir qu'il était contre ouais on
va commencer par là dire un mot de
l'accord charlan Bezina est-ce que c'est
une promesse tenable ou est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron s'est engagé dans une
voie périlleuse Emmanuel Macron s'est
engagé dans une voie il a ouvert un peu
la boîte de Pandor on l'a dit beaucoup
de régions peuvent avoir le sentiment
d'avoir des besoins d'autonomie
néanmoins il a été prudent parce que
l'autonomie ça n'est pas nécessairement
l'indépendance et encore une fois
l'autonomie qu'est-ce que c'est euh quel
sera le champ de cette autonomie
qu'est-ce qu'on va laisser de plus à la
Corse qu'à un autre territoire ce sont
des questions qui sont resté largement
ouverte par le chef de l'État qui
d'ailleurs en se rangeant derrière le
consensus montre bien que on le sait la
voie des révisions constitutionnelles
étant très étroite euh prend quand même
avec beaucoup de prudence la voix de
cette évolution néanmoins c'est vrai que
dès lors qu'on parle de l'autonomie d'un
territoire alors avec la Corse il y a en
effet une histoire il y a des choses qui
ont permis à la Corse de se revendiquer
aussi en terme de démocratie locale de
sans cesse plus d'autonomie mais elle a
déjà un statut particulier la Corse donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut inscrire de nouveau
dans la Constitution pour faire évoluer
le statut de ce territoire c'est ça la
vraie question qu'il faut se poser
est-ce que c'est de l'autonomie plus
fiscale est-ce que c'est une autonomie
de législation comme on le connaît pour
l'outreem mais est-ce que ça se justifie
vraiment par les particularités
territoriales il y a beaucoup de
questions qui sont en en chantier et sur
lesquelles d'ailleurs le territoire
lui-même a pas forcément toujours eu une
position claire donc c'est c'est je
pense que ça passera par beaucoup de
consultations avant qu'on sache
exactement ce que c'est que cette
autonomie est- ce qu'elle promet aussi
peut-être à d'autres régions savoir ce
qu'on met derrière ce mot autonomie le
chemin est encore long Jean-Philippe
deosier oui probablement c'est
souhaitable pour vous que l'autonomie de
l'accord soit écoutez j'ai j'ai j'ai
piloté depuis le mois de janvier dernier
un groupe de réflexion sur l'évolution
de la Constitution et des institutions
qui s'appelle le greky nous avons remis
les les conclusions présenté nos
conclusions et nos propositions hier ici
au Palais du Luxembourg eu nous avons
fait 130 propositions articulé autour de
17 thèmes qui couvrent tous les champs
constitutionnel le seul qu'on a laissé
de côté c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie
parce que nous avons jugé que c'est un
sujet politique avant d'être un sujet
constitutionnel et nous ne faisons pas
de de politique c'était un un groupe
exclusivement composé
d'universitaire mais nous avons couvert
le champ des collectivités territoriales
en revanche il y a des propositions que
nous n'avons pas faites et parmi
cellees-ci il y a la Corse nous n'avons
pas proposé de constitutionaliser la
Corse je peux pas vous dire que nous
sommes tous contre mais je peux vous
dire que personne n'a jugé bon de le
mettre sur sur la table sans doute parce
que la Constitution actuelle permet déjà
des statuts particuliers ce dont
bénéficie la Corse nous avons proposé
également la différenciation entre
collectivités territoriale de de même
niveau nous avons proposé des évolutions
du droit droit constiuel de
l'outreem mais concernant la Corse je
pense que on peut faire un certain
nombre d'évolutions encore y compris
vers l'autonomie dans le cadre de la
Constitution actuelle et vous jugez que
là il y a pas une question politique
bien sûr que si également également mais
c'est précisément parce que la Corse
elle aussi en tant que telle est une
question politique que nous n'avons pas
visé et que nous sommes restés dans le
cadre constitutionnel général pour faire
des propositions plus plus général mais
la question de constitutionnaliser la
Corse aurait pu être présentée elle ne
l' pas été encore une fois ça veut pas
dire que nous sommes nous y sommes tous
opposés mais le le le est-ce que il
s'agit derrière l'autonomie de conférer
un pouvoir législatif à la Corse cela en
effet avec notre Constitution n'est pas
possible mais c'est ouvrir un petit peu
la boîte de Pandore et on l'a vu la
Corse ça a été proposé ou insinué à
l'égard de la Corse tout de suite la
région Bretagne dit et moi puis nouvelle
aquitenne va dire et moi et puis et
cetera et puis la la la la la la con
l'Alsace voilà donc on va en avoir
partout et et ça va aboutir à des
inégalités moi je je suis pas atile à ce
qu'il y ait des sur le plan
constitutionnel des adaptations en
fonction des territoires mais à
condition que l'on reste dans l'égalité
républicaine rappelons bien que dans les
états fédéraux où il y a précisément
cette cette autonomie législative il y a
une égalité entre les États fédérés pour
veiller à ce que il y en a pas qui soit
plus privilégié que d'autes aut qu'il y
ait des déséquilibres fiscaux notamment
entre les territoires qui remettent en
cause cette égalité républicaine audelà
de la Corse il a parlé de la
décentralisation Emmanuel Macron d'une
architecture territoriale à repenser ça
devient inéluctable d'aller plus loin
sur la voie de la décentralisation là
encore est-ce que c'est vraiment la
Constitution le bon vecteur ça n'est pas
garanti d'autant que l'essentiel
des des éléments de frustration on va
dire de nos territoires sont financiers
notamment parce que on a a déjà dans la
Constitution un principe constitutionnel
qu'on prive de sa nature qui est celui
de l'autonomie financière et si vous ne
donnez pas de financeces à des
collectivités auxqueles vous donnez des
pouvoirs constitutionnels en réalité
vous ne leur donnez pas de pouvoir donc
c'est ce que disent les élus qui a une
remise en cause de ce principe
constitution exactement donc je crois
que aller plus loin sur ce terrain c'est
aussi aller plus loin au niveau des
moyens ce qui n'est pas
forcément à mon avis nécessaire dans
dans dans le cadre de la Constitution
néanmoins aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation en permettant de de
régler les problèmes là où les problèmes
émergent on l'a vu avec le coronavirus
les les communes sont en première ligne
je crois que c'est vraiment important de
leur donner un gage de confiance et si
ça doit passer par une inscription
constitutionnelle pourquoi pas mais
encore une fois là encore je crois qu'on
a toujours utiliser la Constitution dans
ce discours d'hier comme une espèce de
réponse à des questions sociétales à des
questions à des revendication locale
territoriale et cetera mais la
Constitution n'est pas forcément
toujours le vecteur pour répondre euh à
ces crises-l elles existent des réponses
doivent lui être apportées mais ça n'est
pas cette inscription dans le marbre
constitutionnel qui règlera le problème
bien au contraire elle peut accentuer
encore les frustrations surtout au
niveau local où voilà rappelons-le c'est
avant tout de confiance et de moyens que
nos collectivité ont besoin jeanf
oui décentralisation ne doit pas arimer
avec disparition de l'État il faut pas
que la décentralisation soit un
désengagement de l'État dans les
territoires et et le nud gordien est
financier et quand on décentralise on
confèt transfèt une compétence aux
collectivités territoriales il y a la
compensation financière qui est prévue
mais elle est prévue à l'instanté au
moment mais financier mais est-ce qu'il
y a pas aussi un problème de clarté des
compétences de qui fait quoi a ça aussi
mais le premier sujet est financier on
on transfère les routes au département
elles sont en bon état au moment où on
transfère donc le financement des routes
coûte un certain prix sauf que avec les
années ce prix augmente pas seulement
avec l'augmentation du prix près de la
vie parce que il y a la véucité il y a
l'entretien qu'il faut faire de plus en
plus et et et cela n'est plus compensé
par l'État et précisément parmi les
propositions qui ont pu être faites au
sein du greky de mon groupe et bien il y
a celle qui doit tenir compte et ça doit
être inscrit dans la Constitution tenir
compte de l'évolution du coût de ces
transferts pour que au fil des années
l'état compense davantage si c'est
nécessaire parce que précisément il y a
ces augmentations un dernier mot parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a dit beaucoup a de
chos on en a un peu parlé un référendum
décentralisation IVG est-ce qu'il est en
capacité politique de faire une réforme
constitutionnelle d'ampleur pas sans
ouvrir beaucoup sa majorité pas sans
avoir des sujets très consensuels et ça
n'est pas du tout le cas des
propositions qu'il a fait hier donc
c'est c'est c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup de mots pour à mon avis un
engagement politique qui va être très
risqué la la à mon avis le le le vrai
problème des réformes constitutionnelles
ça a souvent avant était le Sénat encore
le mot problème est à prendre entre
guillemets c'està direire que c'est
vraiment un blocage une capacité de
blocage qu'à le Sénat et dont il ususe à
à l'envie on va dire et le Sénat est
certes un allié de taille sur les
questions de décentralisation sur les
questions territorial parce qu'il les
connaît de très près mais voilà je pense
que le Sénat se méfie aussi des
questions un peu artificielles et que
donc il faudra le convaincre sur le fond
avec le référendum sur l'immigration ça
n'est pas sûr que ce soit la bonne
manière de de lui parler donc là où on
mettra d'accord le Sénat on mettra pas
forcément d'accord l'Assemblée nationale
et on le rappelle à part en passant
directement par l'article 11 ce qui
n'est même pas une loi de réforme
constitutionnelle d'après ce que prévoit
la Constitution on est obligé de mettre
les deux assemblées dans les mêmes
termes et le président a plusieurs fois
rappelé si un consensus se dégage si une
majorité est trouvée donc à l'heure
actuelle la capacité
politique c'est c'est quoi c'est c'est
c'est positif parce que tout le monde va
trouver quelque chose qui lui convient
ou au contraire tout le monde va trouver
une bonne raison de dire non je pense
que c'est positif pour les LR à
l'Assemblée nationale au moins sur cette
question du référendum ça peut le
référendum et quelque chose qui peut
apparaître assez consensuel même si la
représentation nationale peut y voir
encore une fois cette concurrence et
légitimité mais on ne l'espère pas euh
ça sera plus tendantieux sur l'autonomie
et encore une fois tout va être question
de périmètre je pense que si on a une
réforme constitutionnelle on aura
beaucoup de débats beaucoup d'heures de
débat très intéressantes parce que il
faudra mettre tout le monde d'accord et
ça ça n'est pas gagné et ça a pas marché
dans le quinquena précédent
Jean-Philippe deosier ça a échoué en
2019 estce que là ça a plus de chance de
marcher je je suis assez sceptique vous
savez j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai bien écouté le
discours du président de la République
tant mieux que j'étais en face de lui au
Conseil constitutionnel et dans
l'arrière ban mais moi je l'ai trouvé
extrêmement
creux le discours était intéressant
c'était un bel hommage à cette jeune
dame qui est la constitution de la 5e
République mais creux sur le plan des
ambitions constitutionnel qu'a-t-il
annoncé d'innouvant d'ambitieux la seule
PE peut-être légère innovation nouveauté
c'est que il a dit qu'il voulait aller
plus loin sur l'IVG que il voudrait que
le Congrès aboutisse ce qui veut dire
qu'il est prêt à reprendre un projet de
loi constitutionnel à à son compte je
crois que c'est la première fois qu'il
le dit aussi clairement mais mais
sinon par jusqu'à présent cas on attend
vous savez qu'en matière d'IVG il y a un
délai donc bon il faut faire peut-être
activer un petit peu les choses mais en
tout
cas sur le reste c'était des sujets qui
ont été ressassés est-ce que ça peut
aboutir peut-être que s'il y avait peu
d'ambition c'est parce qu'il a
conscience que les conditions politiques
ne sont pas réunies pour que cela
aboutisse toute révision
constitutionnelle qui arrive à son terme
et qui réussit est apportée à la gloire
du chef de l'État parce que c'est lui
qui l'a initié c'est lui qui l'pportter
et vous avez parlé de 2019 de 2018
effectivement là il y a eu un échec moi
je me souviens surtout de 2016 sous le
Quinquela encore avec François Hollande
Jean-Jacques urvoiss ministre de la
Justice dit au Sénat on reprend votre
texte et le Sénat dit non euh maintenant
c'est trop tard même si vous reprenez
votre texte et qu'on va au Congrès on ne
le votera pas à suivre à suivre c'est on
va continue en parler puisque c'est à la
une de la presse régionale ce
[Musique]
matin et Audrey ce discours d'Emmanuel
Macron devant le conseil concite ça fait
la une de nos quotidiens régionaux oui
est-ce que retiennent les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace c'est qu'Emmanuel
Macron a adressé des pistes pour réviser
la Constitution sans la révolutionner on
l'a dit il veut étendre les sujets
ouverts au référendum favoriser celui
d'initiative partager tout changer pour
ne rien changer juge même assez
sévèrement le dauphinet libéré Corse
Matin va plus loin en évoquant ces
autres régions on en a parlé qui
aimerait bien emboîter le pas de l'île
de beauté je vous l'avais dit la
Bretagne l'Alsace la nouvelle Aquitaine
l'occcitanie en nouvelle Aquitaine le
président socialiste Alain Rousset
demande au moins plus de pouvoir
normatif pour éviter le millefeuille
tout le monde veut faire tout le monde
veut tout faire pardon explique-t-il
quand on ambitionne de faire une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire par exemple
il faut être au moins se derrière le
ruban donc il ironise le président qui
rajoute nous sommes autorisés à nous
occuper de la partie bâtiment mais pas
juger assez intelligent pour le reste
puisque par exemple pour l'enseignement
ça nous échappe le modèle de
décentralisation français pardon et pour
moi de plus en plus humiliant ce matin
il est aussi question de pauvreté et de
pouvoir d'achat oui les Haut- de France
qui grimpe sur la deuxè marche d'un
triste podium nous annonce le Courrier
Picard 2e région la plus pauvre de
France M méropolitaine après la Corse
plus d'un million d'habitants sont
concernés en Bretagne c'est la demande
de logements sociaux qui explose 30000
demandes supplémentaires qui ont été
adressées aux organismes entre 2019 et
2023 96000 en tout et parmi les
populations il y en a qui n'arrivent
plus à se loger dans le privé Orian et
qui se tourne vers le social et puis
l'actualité n'est pas très réjouissante
non plus en matière de pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation alimentaire reste forte et
le PDG de Système U nous prévient dans
la Dépêche du Midi nous ne retrouverons
pas les prix d'avant la guerre en
Ukraine alors pour terminer sur une une
note un peu plus positive et pas vous
déprimer de grand matin je vous propose
la montagne qui s'intéresse au girl
power à ces femmes qui sont chefs
d'entreprise avec en page intérieure un
dessin de presse solide ce plafond de
verre mais il ne pouvait pas nous
résister plus longtemps et des portraits
de femmes à retrouver dans le quotidien
des femmes à la tête d'entreprise depuis
plusieurs années Ophélie Fanton qui gère
des agences d'assurance ellisabeth
valado qui cogère une conserverie voilà
c'est la note positif
l'exemple inspirant et c'est à retrouver
dans la montagne orienne c'est bien on
termine sur du positif merci Audrey
merci beaucoup merci Anne Charl beina
d'avoir ét avec nous on é ravi de
recevoir dans ce club merci
Jean-Philippe de rosier d'être venu
également merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à 18h vous avez rendez-v avec
Thomas HUG pour sens public et nous on
se retrouve demain notre invité ce sera
niè Buzin qui publie son journal pendant
la crise du covid merci à tous très
bonne
journée